and literally says
I'm being wrongfully evicted by you and I'm gonna call the cops
he has no lease
so a lot of girls need to realise when these hobosexuals wanna come
they wanna like crash on your couch cause their ex is so crazy
blah blah blah
they are gonna become a squatter
they will eventually claim that they are a tenant in that house
you will get in trouble for your lease
or you won't be able to kick them out if you're the one that owns the house
because now they have a legal right to say
I'm a tenant in this house
so even when you wanna break up with them
you're gonna have a really fucking hard time getting rid of them
because now it's not about a boyfriend girlfriend thing
it's about fucking legal tenancy and like leases and shit
so do not let a fucking homeless man crash on your fucking couch
for the same reason